for more on what today's warrant
actually means we're now going to turn
to harmeet dillon she is a phenomenal
attorney and the chairwoman of the
republican national lawyers association
uh harmeet thank you so much for joining
us you have been watching this as it has
played out kind of moment by moment what
do you make of these new developments
that we've just learned today
well what we know that has been
confirmed by the search warrant being
revealed is that it was extremely broad
like shannon just pointed out
and what we don't know
and what everybody wants to know is what
was the justification presented to a
federal judge
to take this extraordinary step on the
part of the united states department of
justice and so
generally speaking that search warrant
affidavit or affidavits are not unsealed
until there's an indictment and even
then if their national security
implications they could be restricted to
the
target of that subpoena and the uh or
the search warrant rather and his
attorneys and so it's going to be a
while probably before we see that and i
suspect that the department of justice
is not keen to reveal exactly why they
took this step but what we can also say
is that um a federal magistrate judge
does have the ability and in fact i
think the duty to cut back on a subpoena
that seems overbroad for the
circumstances now in reality they often
just rubber stamp them that's a real
problem in our judicial system and i
think that's what happened here and i
really am my mind is blown that this can
be a justified search of a former
president and so this is deeply
troubling for anybody who cares about
civil liberties in our country
i i couldn't agree more has there been
any discussion or what are what possible
steps could be taken to explore any
potential conflict of interest given
this specific judge who approved this
warrant given his
previous
political contributions and and kind of
political leanings
well just about every judge these days
has some political leanings or
contributions that itself is not a
problem but this specific judge has made
specific negative remarks about
president trump and i think they rise to
the level of recusal but at this point
after the judge has already issued this
ex parte search warrant which is how it
goes there's really nothing that can be
done to unwind that specifically but a
party who believes that a search warrant
has been executed unlawfully or it is
overbroad or what have you can make
certain motions in the criminal system
there's rule four and there's some other
moves that can be made to get the return
of this evidence but there are many
fishy things about this so we'll see
including the fact that the government
apparently was given access to these
documents in june and uh their request
to the former president was to put a
padlock on the room and everybody went
away and thought that this was all under
control on the trump side and then
suddenly they come in with this sort of
librarian uh issued swat team to take
these drastic steps and and i think that
that is very odd and what it seems to me
and i'm not changing my view based on
seeing the search warrant this was a
massive fishing expedition to see if
they could concoct any evidence of
anything that is not how warrants are
supposed to work in america and and that
should outrage every civil libertarian
yeah i couldn't agree more this is about
so much more than whether or not people
support trump or against trump this is
something that is directly
connected to every one of our civil
liberties uh thank you so much harmeet i
really appreciate your analysis as
always
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight